hello Budapest and good afternoon
everybody
I'm sure you all had a good lunch I hope
you all don't sleep after the end of 30
minutes so I'll try my best to keep
y'all awake alright let's get started
so yes technology has already become
more productive and more natural more
intuitive the interfaces are more
intuitive more natural now having
interfaces this way makes the user
understand the product better or like
come closer with it so here I am Prince
iam working for a solando in Berlin and
to talk about natural user interfaces
using javascript so we typed we clicked
touched next what next next could be
alright I will go to the next slide with
a demo and the demo is highly dependent
on light so I really hope it works
okay so two slides again so we typed
clicked touched next what yeah so this
is what I am going to talk to y'all
about natural user interfaces using
javascript
this demo will you go over your so let
me just close it but yes it did its
purpose and yes so it could be gestures
right it could be a speech it could be
anything natural user interfaces could
include touch we typed we clicked touch
was more intuitive than click because it
was more direct next I would say
gestures or speech yes evolution of user
interfaces so somewhere this was coined
somewhere back in the 90s
wherein it started with CLI command line
interface wherein user had to understand
of an artificial medium that is the
keyboard to input something and to
interact with the interface
next came GUI graphical user interface
with the advent of the mouse
users could interact more closely better
than the keyboard with the interface and
understand the interface more better and
now we have this NUI with the advent of
a are we are perceptual computing we
hear that everywhere if we just do a
search on the internet what is the state
of art what we are AR or perceptual
computing there are there is lot
happening out there and anyway has more
space and it is more direct it is more
intuitive yes natural user interfaces to
coin it it is a system for
human-computer interaction wherein users
interact more intuitively more directly
perform more closer tasks these
interfaces are yes are more natural and
more intuitive
yes a quick study about natural user
interfaces revealed this sub info graph
this was taken from the internet a big
it was done and then yeah the results of
a link of a pretty cool because the work
areas where it's targeting that is
entertainment education social
connections health care environment
natural user interfaces has its impact
everywhere so here I am to talk about
anyway plus jeaious and I would coin at
us in you ijs
JavaScript has its broad appeal and it's
because of this broader appeal a lot of
people like to try it and we admit it or
not it is JavaScript which dominates the
web today and yes here is what we are to
celebrate javascript and may javascript
be with all of us so let's talk about nu
IJ s yes this is my the interesting
slide I like to talk about motivation
whenever I like to do something or I
have to do something or I have to
motivate somebody yes so how did this
whole idea start any yjs how did it how
all of this started so it started with
me building trying to build a simulator
for motion control devices or in other
words 3d cameras I have a Whitney or
leap motion today I will talk about more
about it later but yes so the any yjs
started when I was trying to build a
simulator for 3d cameras or motion
control sensors and yes there is another
motivation behind as to how I started to
come up with this idea of trying to
build a simulator so of what what so
happens
oh say oh you are a go yeah Oh your ago
I was trying to trying a talk about
perceptual computing and then I was
trying this intel's realsense sdk and
two days prior to the talk and stole the
story
so please bear with me if you are
listening again two days prior to the
talk
windows and my system crashed and then I
didn't have a backup what to do and I
didn't have backup of my cord and this
SDK which I was trying to walk on solely
relied on Windows and then that's how I
started to think about how about trying
to build some simulator
where then maybe it is a platform
independent or and whether you don't
have to or it is not dependent on any
platform or you don't have to use any
device right so that's how this idea of
simulator originated and then yes the
simulator was there the next was what do
I do with the simulator so next was try
to build some apps for the simulator and
down down those lights I'll be talking
about two apps that is one is the
slideshow which I just showed you all
about using gestures I controlled my
slide it's kind of bad it's like not
very neat it's highly dependent on light
and after to control the frame rates
things like that but yes it's serving
its purpose and the other app I want to
talk about is draw how about imagine
this you grabbing a device and you open
an app do some doodles in the air and
watch your art appear on the screen yes
so I have I have come up with this app
called draw and the other one is slight
so yes that's about like how it all got
started how any ideas started yes before
getting started I had to like try and
understand as to what is this all the
hype about right of method reality
virtual reality perceptual computing
there are so many devices out in the
market augmented reality as the word
augmented says the reality or it is real
the environment is real but there now it
is augmented augmented as an added so
I'm standing here maybe I want to show
some background like Taj Mahal in India
or something else arise on a desert so
I'm mending the reality and that is what
augmented reality is about that's why
where we see augmented reality
applications in real estate things like
that right you're augmenting the reality
next it's about virtual reality what is
this virtual reality about virtual
reality the reality doesn't exist at all
you are like trying to create a virtual
environment you are simulating you are
trying to build an environment which
doesn't exist at all so it could be
assimilated environment then yes we have
this perceptual computing bringing
human-like senses to devices yes there
are like so many devices out there with
support augmented reality virtual
reality perceptual computing
applications and perceptual computing is
making the device understand behave more
like human understand gestures wise
giving more of like human-like
capabilities into the device and that is
perceptual computing perceptual being
able to perceive being able to see oh
yes so I already said there are a lot of
devices out in the market and so yes
what next
there is this motivation somebody
standing here somebody got started and
out of nowhere somebody like got into
this new world there are like so many
devices out in the market people are
already talking about us there is so
much hype about this everybody wants
this baby to fly so there is perceptual
computing and the virtual reality
augmented reality devices everybody
there's so much hype so what next what
next next would be like how do I get
started right so I will tell you about
how I got started and yes how I'll show
you the simulator and I'll show you the
apps and maybe if you are interested
catch me after the talk yes
so as this great man says any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic before we
get into some technical aspects related
to this natural user interfaces I would
like to make a statement here you
after my attempt to build a universal
simulator for all the devices out there
with this one-woman army standing here I
finally gave up and thought of you know
focusing on something one and trying to
really get it right and then maybe like
you know use the same old thing and Here
I am I have chosen this leap motion
controller
yes we are all here at a GS conf
I'm not here to advertise about any
device but please excuse me if I am
talking about leap motion I don't want
to talk about it in particular but it's
a humble effort by a JavaScript
enthusiast to try out something there
and to share it with the community so if
at all I have chosen leap motion it is
just a random choice and yes I just got
lucky I was gifted with this leap motion
and that was the first obvious choice to
try other sleep motion and try to build
a simulator for leap motion now when I'm
talking about simulator the simulator is
nothing but so any of these devices they
will come with your SDK even this leap
motion comes with the SDK and my
simulator what it does is you can try
out the SDK without actually using this
hardware so you have this service
running or software running and then you
can get the whole SDK running without
actually using the sleep motion and you
can see how to get started and who would
get benefit out of this say you're
trying to create a workshop or next
tutorial for a larger audience and then
people don't have the actual hardware or
are really interested to try something
and want to get their hands dirty first
before like buying out something then
yes this is the solution
alright so irrespective of if it's a
leap motion or anything we need to
understand as to how the whole
architecture works so there are all
these devices which we connect with to a
computer using this USB cable and what
happens is this USB controller reads the
sensor data and these are devices it
depends on the device depends on the
manufacturer depends on the company or
manufacturing of the device as to how
they want to yeah its left at them yes
there would be like few 2d or 3d cameras
there would be infrared sensors to sense
your to recognize what's happening
and so this USB controller reads the
sensor data the next what happens this
data is stored in local memory next data
is then streamed by our USB to the SDK
it is the streaming thing which is of
prime importance and we need to
understand what happens when we actually
do the streaming so to understand more
about how the sleep ocean would work
yeah so what happens here is we have
this USB controller and then there is
sleep service running in there
now once the USB controller reads the
sensor data stores it in local memory
and then again streams it back to the
usb so what happens is once the image
data is streamed to your computer then
the whole of this mat world comes into
picture the bunch of these algorithms
which come into play which may be like
eliminate noise and just give the region
of interest to you so there is this lot
of processing happening behind and then
again it's device dependent as to how
they want to process and how they were
in what format they want to or give the
data to the SDK so in this case what
happens is there's a sleep service and
the other good thing is all of these
devices they are connected to the USB
port and the way they stream data after
reading the sensor data storing local
memory are the way they stream it is
happening through a protocol slide up so
if it's a network or native than it is
TCP protocol and then if it is web-based
it is WebSockets and I'm here to talk
about a web-based solution so it's all
about WebSockets all of these SDKs they
create a WebSocket server and then they
do the streaming back to the application
and that is how the application is able
to get back the data in this case leap
service would have its WebSocket server
running in 6 4 3 7 port number 6 437 so
next I'll show you
some code and I have like uploaded it
here I'll be sharing the slides and yes
there were like few references which
have used there were this good open
source libraries out there webcam Swiper
and GS object detector
so the first thing what I'm here to show
y'all about is the app called draw right
so I have this app called draw which
works the same code works with leap
motion and works without leap motion and
this draw what it does is right now I've
just enabled it for like one finger I
just move one finger and then I'm able
to like you know track my finger
movements and draw something on the
screen so this is what the app does and
it's able to run with the device or
without the device now a little more
about the simulator all these devices
they use this web sock they use this
WebSocket server for the streaming
process and what I do is I create the
simulate the idea of the simulator is to
create a no J's WebSocket server and
this WebSocket server can run on any
port and all you have to do is you have
to configure your SDK to talk to your
WebSocket server instead of the SDK
server which works which works if a
device is connected so if your device is
not connected we run the web server
server and then we send in the or data
so let's see how this draw works so
first I will of shot show or draw with a
leap motion controller so now I'm
connecting the sleep motion I have this
connected and I have my WebSocket server
running on port number 3000 and sorry so
now I'm using the leap motion so I don't
want my WebSocket server so this part by
default it talks to the leap motions
WebSocket server which is running on 6 4
3 7 and let's do this so ok I'm not sure
about the light
yeah the demos okay now everything is
good maybe because of the light
yeah okay so it's moving
okay please move sorry
was that for me okay can someone turn
the lights up on the stage please
I thought somebody's angry I'm sorry
okay let me just stand here and
okay
oh no no it has to walk let's make it
walk please bear with me
I think this is so unavoidable right no
matter how short that your demo is when
you are presenting it has to break this
is just not moving okay let me just try
the leap motion yeah okay so uh fine the
motion is not working so I'll just try
my simulator and let's see if that is
working to make my simulator run all I
have to do is I'll be telling look into
the port 3000 I can obviously make my
WebSockets overrun at 6 4 3 7 where in
the leap motions default WebSocket
server is running at but yes I prefer
3000 here so I save it and I have this
my WebSocket running yes ok so now this
application what I've done is it's
basically WebSocket right so it is a
client-server model so this screen what
you see is a client and then there is
the server which has to send signals to
the WebSocket and then the WebSocket
will send back the signals to all the
connected clients so the architecture
looks like my two browsers
so long so and then it is so draw yeah
okay
okay this is not running either so the
idea was right now what I'm doing is
it's the same code but then I'll unplug
the sleep motion it's the same code I
just want to see the output
but so the idea was I am passing the
coordinates so I know what sort of data
format the leap motion expects I have my
server running so I'm you know moving
the mouse coordinates I'm moving the
mouse coordinates and then it's sending
the data to the WebSocket server and
then the WebSocket server sends back the
data to the leaped line so in this case
this is my application what you see or
hear where when you see the blue dot is
supposed to be the client and then this
mouse part oh yeah
all right so right now it's the same
leap motion code I'm not using gestures
so I'll come to the gestures part later
I'm just a user using my mouse touchpad
and then I'm able to do this doodles on
the screen it's not a good noodle but
yes the idea is they're being able to
draw something so I have my this server
sitting here which is taking coordinates
taking the positions it would be the
same way as though like you have your
gestures and then the gestures are being
recognized by the leap motion and then
it's sure you know it's taken by the
application yes
so let's look into the code what happens
here this is my WebSocket server few
lines of code and this is all you need
to create a WebSocket server and my
application the server part which acted
like a server which had to give data to
the WebSocket server and then this web
sockets over the one running at 3,000
would give back to the application the
draw application so in this case yeah
all I'm doing is I'm just up getting my
mouse coordinates and then I'm creating
this you know I'm sending through
WebSocket server and I'm sending the
hands and the point Able's so leap
motion has this data or JSON format and
this is the kind of API which the leap
motion expects so it will look for like
other any gestures are there hands hands
yes leap motion is able to okay it's too
much like leap motion is able to
identify which hand it is if it is right
hand or if it is left hand and the point
tables refer to the fingers so I am
referring to the index finger and this
is how I'm walking the data so I tell
you know the point Able's and I'm
passing up the index finger right so it
will be like an array of 5 or 0 1 2 3
and forth so I'm passing up the data for
the first finger index finger and then
I'm calling the tip position where it is
the X and the y coordinates so the tip
position is actually a vector in 3d
space XYZ but then I'm capturing or 3
coordinates and then I'm giving to a
WebSocket server and then this WebSocket
server gives to the leap so in the sleep
what it happened was it's the same code
which you have to run if a device is
connected or no and yes so if you're
connecting the device just uncommon the
second line it will refer to the default
port which is running on 6 4 3 7
otherwise it will love there are four on
three thousand so let the lights meet
there I'll just try with leap motion
again so I am NOT referring to my local
server but then I am referring to my
leap motion now
in this case I would only need one
because okay yeah so okay
finally yeah so I think I don't know if
I have time but yes the demo of just
broke a bit and I got little nervous and
but yes it did its job so this is the
whole idea and you already saw how I
control the slideshow with gestures so
then what's happening is in the first
draw app what I'm doing is I'm passing
the coordinates okay excuse me from
talking superfast now I'm excited
because my demo work and enough running
out of time but sure can I get five more
minutes please okay okay fine so the
idea is the way the slides are connected
right so when I had to connect the
slides it was gestures and not any mouse
coordinates so here what happens is I
had to learn a few things about computer
vision and the library saw which I've
mentioned are already out there there is
also this ah good thing load OpenCV and
two good libraries that is jeaious
object detect which were like very good
yeah so uh this is a very good object
detection algorithm used in computer
vision I'm not any open Seanie expert
but then yes when I was doing this up I
had to learn a little bit about this so
up in the gestures in the slideshow
there were like two things so I had this
my app running on a browser window and
then it obviously was talking to the
leap motion or SDK but I didn't use the
leap motion device I had to uh I gave
the signals through my hand now this
hand this hand signals obviously came
from the load socket web server now how
this hand was detected was using this
wire Jones algorithm and first it was
feature selection I have to understand
what my hand
and then creating uh you know we do the
grayscale so that noise is eliminated
then do some math on it get an integral
image and do some other boosts training
like you know train it and get some
classifiers and make this up you know
are features of the hand map to the
classifier which is already trained and
then yes you know it is a hand and then
this hand coordinates of the hand I know
I can locate the coordinates of the hand
it was this coordinate of the hand which
were sent to the WebSocket server and
the WebSocket server a knew which
position it was there was some logic
written if it is this side then it is
left or if it is this side it is right
and then now give back to my slide
application so this is all how it was
about so yes this was a humble effort
and then there were few other things
about web sockets and getusermedia to
know more about this I am doing this
session at the Mozilla hacker launch
tomorrow at 3:15
if y'all are interested so come and
learn to learn to create a selfie or
sharing session using WebSockets and get
user media so you will understand more
about this client-server architecture
water which is used in the simulator and
yes so this was a humble effort by a
JavaScript enthusiast to do something
and share it with y'all I hope you all
enjoyed and I'm really glad this demo
worked thanks to James Caan's VP of and
solando for getting me here questions
y'all can't eat with me or I'll be
around today and tomorrow
please up give me your feedback what you
felt about it and yes solando is hiring
you can come and talk to us alright
thank you so much thanks for listening
you